The second season of The Umbrella Academy
may have answered some of our biggest lingering
questions from season one, but it raised a
bunch more of its own.
Here are some of the biggest questions we're
still wondering about after finishing The
Umbrella Academy season two.
In the first season of The Umbrella Academy,
we meet the Hargreeves siblings' "mom," Grace,
whom we quickly learn is actually a robot.
However, in season two, Diego runs into Grace
again at a gala in 1963 -- only this time,
she's a real, flesh and blood person.
It turns out that Grace is a scientist dating
Reginald Hargreeves, the enigmatic Hargreeves
family patriarch, and has no knowledge of
any of his shadier dealings.
Diego urges Grace to look closer at her boyfriend's
business in Dallas, telling her that Reginald
is planning to assassinate the president.
Although Grace insists that Diego is mistaken,
she does take his advice, and finds evidence
of the assassination conspiracy.
She confronts Hargreeves, who doesn't refute
any of her suspicions, but tells her there
are some parts of his life he just can't discuss
with her.
"Someday, I hope to share it all with you.
Until then, I'm asking you to trust me."
This doesn't seem to go over well with Grace.
The last we see of her, she's walking away
from Reginald, seemingly for good.
It raises a lot of questions, including how
the robot version of Grace eventually came
into being in the original timeline, and whether
Diego's interference has changed Grace's fate.
Season one of The Umbrella Academy revealed
that 43 babies were spontaneously conceived
and birthed on October 1, 1989, and that Hargreeves
only managed to adopt seven.
That leaves 36 still out there, somewhere.
With the introduction of Lila, we get our
first glimpse of what might have befallen
some of those other children.
Like the Hargreeves siblings, Lila has superpowers,
but her childhood was markedly different from
theirs.
It begs the question of how many other superpowered
"siblings" are out there, if any of them have
found one another, and why we haven't heard
anything about them yet.
Right on the heels of learning that she is
actually a long-lost Hargreeves "sibling,"
Lila grabs a briefcase and splits for destinations
unknown.
Although Luther could have stopped her, Diego
intervenes, admitting that he's fallen in
love with her.
But where did Lila go?
With a Commission briefcase, she could travel
to literally any point in history.
And without a functional Commission to monitor
her, she could probably get away with quite
a lot.
Will she go to 1993, to attempt to save her
parents from the Handler and Number Five?
Will she jump further into the future, to
try to reunite with Diego?
One of the more poignant storylines from season
one revolved around the eccentric Klaus accidentally
spending several years fighting in the Vietnam
War.
During that time, he fell in love with a fellow
soldier named Dave, who was tragically killed
in action.
In season two, though, Klaus sees another
chance to save Dave when he finds himself
back in the '60s, this time several years
before his first trip back.
Unfortunately, Klaus' plan isn't very well
thought out, and he winds up getting punched
in the face for his troubles.
Yet despite Klaus' bumbling, he does actually
manage to change something.
"I've already enlisted."
"What?
That's not supposed to happen yet."
Klaus assumes this means he's doomed, but
maybe not.
Perhaps Dave's earlier enlistment date will
lead to other, bigger changes down the line.
Could Klaus actually have managed to save
Dave after all?
We don't know, but we're holding out hope.
When young Harlan accidentally drowns midway
through season two, Vanya uses her newly rediscovered
powers to lift the water out of the lake and
revive him.
During the process, she inadvertently passes
some of her powers to him, although she doesn't
realize it at the time.
Later, Vanya realizes Harlan is linked to
her, and that her own trauma has triggered
his powers.
Harlan's powers quickly spiral out of control,
but Vanya is ultimately able to calm Harlan
enough to approach him and draw his powers
back into herself -- or so she thinks.
At the end of the season, Harlan's mother,
Sissy, makes the hard choice to say goodbye
to Vanya, since she worries that Vanya's abilities
will put a target on her back that would put
Harlan in danger.
Sissy just wants a normal, safe life for her
son, and decides to take him to California
to start over.
However, the last time we see Harlan, he's
making a toy bird levitate in his hand in
the back seat of his mother's car, implying
that Vanya didn't drain all of his powers
after all.
What other abilities does Harlan still have,
and how will those powers and his traumatic
experience in Dallas help shape the rest of
his life?
We hope we'll find out in season three.
One of the odder parts of the 1960s storyline
is the cult Klaus starts, thanks to his tendency
to spout song lyrics that haven't been written
yet as if they're prophecies, and his ability
to use his dead brother to perform seemingly
impossible feats.
Egged on by Klaus' own ego and aversion to
conflict, Klaus' cult quickly winds up taking
on a life of its own, and by 1963, he's amassed
quite the following.
Although Klaus does eventually attempt to
make things right, revealing to his followers
that he's a fraud before leaving with his
siblings to save the world and return to 2019,
the cult members mistake his confession for
another pearl of enlightenment.
Despite Klaus' departure, the closing moments
of season two indicate that his cult is far
from over.
They're still driving around in a rainbow-hued
bus, picking up new acolytes along the way.
It'll be interesting to see if the cult is
still around in 2019, how it has changed over
the intervening 56 years, and, perhaps most
intriguingly, how the group will react to
the return of their Prophet, still looking
exactly the same as he did when he disappeared
in 1963.
When the Hargreeves siblings arrive back in
2019, they're shocked and relieved to find
both their father and their previously deceased
brother Ben are still alive.
But their excitement is short-lived when neither
Reginald Hargreeves nor Ben seems to have
any idea who they are, nor what the Umbrella
Academy is.
"This is the Umbrella Academy."
"Wrong again.
This is the Sparrow Academy."
The name change is mystifying, since the Umbrella
Academy was named for the umbrella factory
where Hargreeves set up shop shortly after
arriving on Earth.
He was still operating out of this same umbrella
factory in the 1963 that the Hargreeves siblings
departed before jumping to 2019, so it's curious
that the academy doesn't bear its name.
Could someone else have named the Sparrow
Academy, and if so, what is their role in
the organization?
Is Hargreeves still in charge, or is he now
reporting to someone else?
And what significance does the name "Sparrow"
hold?
We can't help but think about how Harlan ended
the season using his powers to levitate a
toy bird.
Coincidence?
We'll see.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
Netflix shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.